Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav und ich begrüße alle zur sechsundfünfzigsten Ausgabe von UKW. Es ist äh doch so einiges dazu gekommen
Und heute ist mal nicht Corona Time, äh das Corona Wickly, das kommt dann in der nächsten Sendung. Nein, das wird mal Zeit
mal nachzuschlagen im großen Buch Brexit und mal herauszufinden, was da eigentlich passiert ist und dafür begrüße ich erstmal den John John Worse. Hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Nun ist es also endlich passiert.
Jetzt haben wir den Brexit, nachdem er irgendwie mehrfach schon irgendwie angekündigt war, versucht wurde und so weiter, dann nochmal aufgeschoben war und Übergangsperiode, die ist jetzt abgelaufen,
dreiundzwanzig Uhr am einunddreißigsten zwölften war's dann soweit quasi und dann ja nomor.
Wie fühlt sich das denn an für dich.
Wir wussten alle, dass äh es musste irgendwann zu diesem.
Kommen. Also Großbritannien war schon juristisch aus der EU schon seit dem einunddreißigsten Januar. Also das war.
Keine große Überraschung. Also die die wichtigsten Etappen haben wir alle schon hinter uns. Ähm.
Und ich muss auch sagen, ich war ein bisschen erleichtert, dass es überhaupt zu einem Deal gekommen ist. Äh also das war schon besser als gar nichts. Ähm also grob ähm,
Ja, das war eine wichtige Etappe, aber die sehr traurigen Etappen fanden jetzt schon ein bisschen länger in der der Vergangenheit statt.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich meinte so eher wie es dir so persönlich jetzt so geht.
Nee, also ja, so ist es ein bisschen ist ein bisschen schwierig. Ähm also ich sehe.
Heute wie wie zuvor meine eigene persönliche Zukunft ist in Deutschland. Hier ist wo ich wohne, hier ist bei um meine eigene Zukunft, ist ähm,
und ich bin noch sehr beruhigt, dass ich hier wohne, weil ich kann weiterhin.
So weit wie möglich hier wohnen, wie ich immer gewohnt habe. Ähm also das ist fast uns im im Sachen Brexit so nervt. Ist diese, das, das macht das Leben.
Jetzt für für viele Menschen noch ein Tick schwieriger. Ähm also ich hatte die erste.
Praktische Auswirkung auf meinem Leben. Ich musste ein Paket nach Großbritannien ähm am ähm am zehnten Januar äh losschicken,
Ich musste für das erste Mal dann dieses Zollformular ausfüllen, um zu behaupten, dass in dem Paket es gibt ja
mies wertvolles. Ähm also die sind die kleinen Änderungen, die wir jetzt erfahren werden. Ähm ich habe immer,
diverse Computerzeugs aus Großbritannien von von eBay äh ähm eBay Verkäufer in Großbritannien bestellt. Das werde ich nie mehr in der Zukunft machen, weil die die Protokost.
Sind einfach noch höher ähm als Jesus vor, aus Großbritannien war Großbritannien nicht mehr in der Zollunion ist
Also die sind kleine Änderungen in meinen eigenen Leben, aber für Leute in Großbritannien, die Änderungen sind deutlich größer geworden seitdem seit dem ersten Januar. Natürlich wie schwierig die Auswirkungen sind, wissen wir jetzt nicht, weil es
nicht so viele Austausch von Menschen zwischen Großbritannien und der Rest der EU.
Wegen Kohona und diese Korone Variante in Großbritannien. Also ich denke, das ist für nur echt hart sein für die Briten äh mittelfristig.
Zurück die letzte Sendung war vom elften November zwanzig zwanzig und da haben wir dann so 'ne Da
wir zumindest auf die letzten Tage der Verhandlung geblickt, weil es gab so diverse offizielle Deadlines und
nicht mehr viel Zeit für das Parlament zu tagen und so weiter und so fort. Dann hat es sich dann aber dann doch bis Weihnachten hingezogen. Ich das äh richtig sehe, bis auf den letzten Tag, der überhaupt noch irgendwie ging.
Ja genau, äh also wir wir müssen einige interessanten Schlussfolgerungen ziehen aus dieser Periode.
All das debattiert haben, waren die Positionen,
Besonders ins zwei vielleicht drei Themenfelder sehr weit voneinander. Die waren die Regeln auf für den sogenannten Level Plankfield, also fairer Wettbewerb,
zwischen Großbritannien und die EU. Die Fischereipolitik.
Und dann diese dritte, es ging um Roule Flow und die Regelungen für Nordirland. Also die waren die ersten, wo es dann so eine Einigung.
Kommen ist und das schon ein paar Wochen vor dem vor dem Deadline, also da haben wir richtig viel Druck gesehen aus Washington DC, also das beiden wollte unbedingt eine Lösung in diese.
Die Brexit-Verhandlungen für Nordirland und das war so die erste von den den drei.
Themenfelder, die dann, wo wo die dann sehr schnell eine eine Lösung oder relativ schnell eine Lösung gefunden haben.
Die anderen zwei waren etwas schwieriger und die dann es gab während Wochen fast keine Lösung in Sicht und dann plötzlich alles auf einmal,
Lösung für die beiden Themenfelder. Wir besonders in der Fischereipolitik, also.
Angebot am Anfang von den Briten,
war das während einer fünf Jahre lange Periode Großbritannien wollte achtzig Prozent der Fangrote zurück und das nicht in den Tonnen vom Fisch, sondern in den in den Wert von den Fischen.
Und das das Anfangsposition der EU war achtzehn Prozent, ja, so zwischen achtzehn und achtzig und doch am Ende, die Einigung war für fünfundzwanzig.
Also sehr nah an der an der EU Position und meilenweit von den britischen Positionen.
Sachen Sachen Level Playingfield, was die Briten so akzeptiert haben, war sehr nah an der EU-Position und relativ weit von der der beginn der Position der Brit.
Wieso könnte es so schnell alles so schnell so eine Lösung kommen.
Die große Fragezeichen ist, was am einundzwanzigsten Dezember passiert ist, ja? Also drei Tagen vor der endgültigen Einigung,
Und das war das Ausbruch von dieser neu neue sogenannte britische Korone Variante. Und dann machte plötzlich Frankreich
Grenzen zu, ja? Die Grenzen für alles, nicht nur für Personen, sondern auch für Waren, also nichts ging.
Zwei Tage lang ähm äh auch alle faire Verbindungen waren zwischen Großbritannien und die EU plötzlich geschlossen
es gab riesen langen LKWs vor der Hafen von die haben diese so Notennotfalls so LKW Park äh geöffnet an dem alten Flughafen von Manzen, nicht so weit von Dova.
Diese Bilder von massenhaften LKWs gesehen und da, soweit ich das verstanden habe, da da herrschte dann Panik in Downing Street. Meine Gute, alles kann ihn nachhaupt flachen vierzig Stunden so so schnell schiefgehen.
Das bedeutet, dass wir brauchen unbedingt eine Einigung. Ähm also das ist aus meiner Sicht den den Kernpunkt, also Großbritannien wäre bereit.
Ohne Tiere rauszugehen, aber doch am Ende, es kam so ein Deal unter viel Druck äh wegen dieser, diese Situation äh in der Nähe von Dova äh.
Du das? Denkst du, denkst du das wirklich? Also das wundert mich jetzt so ein bisschen, dass sie, dass sie so auf auf No Deal gegangen sind und nur durch diese Erfahrung haben sie ihre Meinung geändert.
Nee, also die man muss daran denken, dass dass die die praktischen Auswirkungen.
Waren für Boris Johnson nicht sehr wichtig. Es war für ihm egal, was er.
In diese Verhandlungen kriecht? Es war nur was er seine Partei verkaufen könnte.
Und sobald alles ruhig blieb, ja, war dann no Deal noch auf dem Tisch. Ähm.
Und die Positionen, besonders im Bereich der Fischereipolitik, auch ein paar Tagen vor der,
ähm vor der vor dem Deal war die britische Position noch auf sechzig Prozent. Ja in Sachen Quote für für Großbritannien zurück. Also die die Briten haben.
Kamen sehr rasch so ein Kompromiss und das einzige plausiblen Grund, warum die das alles,
so in die letzte Minute gemacht haben, war dann Boris Johnson, könnte sich dann als Retter dann präsentieren. Okay, wir sind in eine schwierige Lage. Ich habe,
alles so gerettet. Ähm.
Ohne diese Krise an der an der Hafen von Dove vor vor Weihnachten ich denk die Chancen sind wären noch hoch, dass er dann bereit war ohne Deal rauszuge.
Mhm. Okay.
Wir werden nie wissen.
Wir werden's vielleicht nie wissen, ja.
Weil grob was ich.
Was ich dann in dieser Phase so so problematisch fand, ist er hat alles zu spät gelassen. Das es gab keine wirklich Erleichterung,
für britischen Unternehmen, weil die hatten dann keins keine Zeit, sich,
auf die Änderungen vorzubereiten. Und das ist, was wir jetzt dran seitdem die gesehen haben, ja? Also es kommen jetzt riesigen Kritik, weil die britischen Firmen waren überhaupt nicht in der Lage, innerhalb von einer Woche, sie schauf die, die für dieses Deal dann vorzubereiten. Ähm also das bedeutet einen möglichen
plus von einem Deal. Diesem Plus wäre größer, wenn er schon den November ein Deal abgeschlossen hätte, ja?
Kann er sagen was habe ich Boris Johnson gewonnen? Weil ich alles bis die letzte Minute äh gelassen habe. Er hat nichts, null, gar nichts
Äh also das ist dann warum ist aus meiner Sicht plausibel ist, dass er kaum nur so nur nur so an die diesen diesem Deal überhaupt wegen diesem den Virusausbruch.
Allright. Na gut, also auf jeden Fall dazu kam's dann, es gab eine Einigung, das heißt, es gibt jetzt einen Trade Deal und der vereinbart.
Eine ganze Menge von äh Dingen. Vielleicht gehen wir mal durch die wichtigsten Punkte durch.
Grundsätzlich korrigiere mich, wenn ich's äh irgendwie falsch abgespeichert habe, aber dass der der Handelsdeal jetzt zwischen UK und EU sagt im Wesentlichen, es gibt Handel von Waren.
Frei.
Genau. Und Quotenfrei.
Unquotenfrei. Also kann im Prinzip so viel verkauft werden wie geht, ja? Aber ähm.
Auch wenn die Zölle null sind, heißt es eben nicht äh single Market, sondern man verhält sich trotzdem gegenüber der EU jetzt wie ein Drittland. Man hat halt nur einen spezifischen Deal, der jetzt zunächst einmal diese Zölle festleg
Das deckt aber im Wesentlichen eben den Handel mit Waren ab, aber es deckt so einiges nicht ab, wofür ja eigentlich UK immer bekannt war und was vor allem einen großen Teil ausmacht, der,
Wirtschaftskraft, nämlich insbesondere die Financial Services beziehungsweise des Services in General, ja?
Genau. Also die Dienstleistungen sind am härtesten hier betroffen. Also es gibt ja sehr wenig in dem Deal, so die wir so
so Dienstleistungen überhaupt. Finanzindustrien, Datenaustausch, auch professionelle Qualifikationen, wenn jemand meine, eine Qualifikation als Jurist in Großbritannien hat, kann diese diese Person dann in anderen Ländern praktizieren
ist nicht geklart in diesem Stil. Ähm also ja äh es gibt noch sehr, sehr viele offene Fragen.
Die EU hat danach auch eine schöne Grafik veröffentlicht auf ihrer Webseite, wo sie mal so alles aufgelistet haben, was so vorher war und was jetzt nicht mehr ist.
Kann man vielleicht mal kurz äh so durchgehen, also dass es hier erstmal grob aufgeteilt in verschiedene äh Gruppen. Das fängt an mit Free Movement of People so und äh das Einzige, was sozusagen erhalten ist, dass man,
neunzig Tage Visa Free Travel hat so, also vorher war es ja im Prinzip,
Man konnte kommen und gehen, weil man, weil man wollte, jetzt ist es halt darauf limitiert, alles über neunzig Tage geht halt nicht, das heißt, man muss dann halt erstmal.
Entweder ein spezielles Visum beantragen oder erstmal wieder zurückkehren, bevor man wieder äh reinkommen darf.
Genau und das betrifft zum Beispiel Briten die Ferienhäuser haben in Spanien
besonders. Ja, Leute, die nicht da arbeiten, wollen aber da nur da die Hälfte des Jahres in Spanien verbracht haben. Diese Leute müssen dann nach einer Periode von neunzig Tagen dann erstmal zurück nach Großbritannien.
Ja. Und was natürlich sehr eingeschränkt ist, ist so Right to Work Studie Lifit Nazar EU Country, also im Wesentlichen existiert das jetzt erstmal nicht. Es gibt aber Ausnahmen wohl.
Ja, ähm, also die, die Hauptausnahmen sind für Menschen, die schon das gemacht haben oder sogenannten ähm äh Crossboard the Workes, also Leute, die dann in einem Land.
Wohnen und in Großbritannien arbeiten oder umgekehrt. Also die Anzahl davon ist nicht enorm groß. Aber da drinne ist eins von den wichtigsten Themenfelder in die Debatte in jetzt wir gesehen haben in den Wochen,
seit dem Austritt ist wie Musiker betroffen äh sind. Also ähm.
Es gab für Musiker aus den Vereinigten Staaten zum Beispiel, die dann Konzerte in Europa machen wollen.
Die dürfen das machen für bis neunzig Tagen wie so Visum frei, ja? In die ganz in das ganze EU,
Und das hat Großbritannien,
nicht verhandelt für britische Musiker. So das bedeutet es gelten sechsundzwanzig unterschiedliche Regelungen für britische Musiker und es gibt dann in den meisten Fällen nur bis dreißig Tage Visum frei.
Und es ist nicht wieso frei für die Mitarbeiter, die Stagehuns, die diversen Techniker. Also das macht dann für britischen ähm Orchestern oder oder die diversen Gruppen. Das machen dann so Tours durch Europa,
deutlich teurer als als zuvor. Es ist ein Beispiel von wie wie das dann eingeschränkt wird für ähm für Brit.
Und dazu muss man ja sagen, ist jetzt nicht irgendwas, die Musikszene ist ja nun, also Großbritannien hat ja eine riesige Wirtschaft, die dahinter steht, das ist sozusagen jetzt nicht äh unwichtig.
Und soweit wir wissen, die EU hat Großbritannien die gleichen Regeln angeboten wie.
Musiker aus den Vereinigten Staaten. Großbritannien hatte dagegen dann dieses Angebot abgelehnt, weil sowas würde bedeuten, äh neunzig Tage wie Visum frei für Musiker aus der EU in Großbritannien
ja? Und das wollen die Briten nicht. Ähm also äh so zu diesen Slogan Take Nuck Control, dass Großbritannien wollt
will Einwanderung irgendwie begrenzen, ja ob ein Musiker aus Frankreich, ein ein großes Gefahr ist, irgendwie für Großbritannien, das hat die britische Regierung natürlich nicht gesagt, ähm aber,
Ja, also das ist wie im blickend und kurzfristig denkend die die britische, die, die jetzt gebrittische Regierung leider ist.
Ja, ich denke das wird dann spätestens denen auffallen, die dann irgendwann einmal derzeit ist das ja gar nicht möglich äh in der EU reisen wollen.
Nicht unbedingt arbeiten wollen. Erstmal gibt es natürlich jetzt richtige Grenzkontrollen. Es gibt kein äh komm mal einfach rein hier EU-Passwort, schön, dass du da bist, sondern man stellt sich an der eigenen Schlange an und muss
Fragen beantworten und was nicht alles. Es gibt auch nicht diese sogenannten
Pasta Sports, dass man äh seine Haustiere so ohne Weiteres mitnehmen kann. Also sehr viel wird im Detail,
extrem kompliziert und ich denke mal, das wird dann auch in zunehmenden Maße den Leuten natürlich auffallen, auch wenn das jetzt durch die Pandemie natürlich verzögert ist.
Genau und das, das haben wir bis jetzt nicht so wirklich erlebt. Also die werden die die Briten werden das erst merken.
Während den Sommerferien oder sobald alles dann wieder anfängt. Was wir schon gesehen haben, ist wie Warenverkehr
auch betroffen ist und besonders Verkehr vom ähm äh Essen
Ja, so von von Agrarprodukte und fertig dieses Essen, ja. Also das ist wirklich als schon ein großes Problem geworden. Also da haben wir schon
Engpässe gesehen in die Lieferungen von ähm ähm frische Gemüse und Obst aus EU-Länder in Großbritannien
Und in der anderen Richtung Exporten ähm vom Fischprodukte aus Großbritannien nach anderen Ländern der EU. Also da haben wir schon die ersten sehr konkrete Auswirkungen schon gesehen.
Und daran hat man vor allem auch ganz gut gesehen, dass es glaube ich eine massive Fehlwahrnehmung der Auswirkungen gab, sowohl natürlich in der Bevölkerung ohnehin, aber offensichtlich auch beim Government,
um diese ganze Fischerei ist ja ein ein riesiges Bohei gemacht worden. Also
war ja gerade so ein religiöser Teil und es war immer so eins dieser Kernargumente, obwohl wir bei der letzten Sendung ja schon betont haben, Fischerei macht einfach so, so, so wenig von der Wirtschaftskraft der UK aus, dass es eh schon unsinnig ist darauf
sich so zu konzentrieren und das sozusagen da so zum zum zum Stückchen zu machen, über das man die EU springen lassen möchte, aber,
Diese Regelung jetzt. Ich habe mir das mal genauer angeschaut, wie diese Quotenregelung eigentlich aussieht, weil diese fünfundzwanzig Prozent, die da verkündet wurden. Das stimmt so eigentlich auch nicht.
Das ist äh erstmal hängt das extrem von der jeweiligen Fischsorte ab. In den, bei den allermeisten Fischsorten gibt es.
Eigentlich überhaupt gar keine Änderung. Ich glaube, das ist sowas äh wie zwei, drei Prozent und das halt auch erst in fünf Jahren,
und dann darüber hinaus muss eh nochmal alles neu verhandelt werden, also.
Ja und was noch am am schlimmsten ist. Also fünfzig Prozent des Wertes von dem Britischen ganzen Briten Fischindustrie
ist nicht Fischen auf dem offenen Meer. Das ist so in Face, ja so in den Lochs, in Schottland,
und ähm besonders äh da da fehlt es mir die Worte auf Deutsch Samen,
äh Samenforming, Lachs, ähm äh Armbau in in Schottland. Also diese, also,
Da gibt's keine Frankenquoten. Äh also und was wirklich ein Problem ist für britische Fischer, egal was für eine Art von Fisch ist.
Ich sitze hier jetzt so schwierig geworden überhaupt das Fisch zu exportieren, ja das es nicht mehr rentabel ist überhaupt zu fischen.
Und es kommen auch hinzu, dass Großbritannien.
So die es gibt, es gibt eine eine so Fichtquotenereinigung zwischen die EU und,
Island und Norwegen, also zwei Nicht-EU-Mitgliedstaaten,
Und weil Großitanien kein Teil mehr ist, der EU, Großitanien ist kein Teil mehr von dieser Einigung mit Norwegen und Island. Also die,
das größte britische Fischboot aus dem Hafen von Hall darf nicht aufs Meer, weil das fängt,
Fischsorten, die in den Norwegischen und isländischen Gewässern zu finden sind. Und es gibt keine Einigung mehr, zwischen Großbritannien und Norwegen und Island.
Und dann die die schottische Fischer die haben ja gefunden, wenn die
kommen so zu den Hafen in Schottland, die können dieses Fisch nicht mehr exportieren. Also schottischen Fische machen ein achtundvierzig Stunden langen Weg nach Dänemark, um überhaupt
Fisch,
verkaufen zu können. Also es ist komplett eine Ehre, es gab vor ein paar Tagen sogar ein Protest von George Fischer, die die sind alle mit einer Schlange von LKWs nach London gefahren, um so eine Art
Protest zu machen vor dem Tendaling Street, weil die sehen das Ganze
ähm äh Lebende der der Fischereiindustrie in Schottland ist zurzeit in Gefahr
Also es sollen vollkommen eine Ehre, weil in zwanzig sechs sehen die Brexit-Befürworter haben gesagt Brexit ist die rechts oben der britische Fischereipolitik,
und in den ersten drei Wochen, seit dem seit dem endgültigen Bereich sind, wir haben gesehen, dass es tötet, die ganze britische Fischerei äh Industrie und besonders die Fischereiindustrien schaut.
Ähm also das ist so wirklich ein Wahnsinn. Also und diese Fischer,
die sind so echt genervt, obwohl die Mehrheit nicht alle für den Brexit gestimmt haben damal.
Ja und vor allem man muss sich das ja auch so vorstellen, man kennt ja.
Demonstrationen von äh von Bauern, auch hier in Deutschland, da kommen sie alle mit ihren Treckern und äh es gibt Proteste und der Milchpreis stimmt nicht und so weiter. Und
das mögen alles berechtigte äh Dinge sein, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie jetzt alle einen Tag später ihre Läden schließen müssen, aber derzeit ist es tatsächlich so, die Großhandelszentren, da wo der Fisch von den Fischern, der gerade gefangen wurde
eingekauft wird, um dann gleich auf den Weg geschickt zu werden, um möglichst schnell zum Kunden zu kommen, sind leer. Da fin,
da findet grade nichts mehr statt. Der Handel ist komplett eingebrochen, weil der Aufwand, den Fisch in die EU zu bringen, wo nämlich der allermeiste in die in UK gefangene Fisch,
verkauft wurde bisher so ein bürokratischer Aufwand geworden ist, dass es so viele Tage dauert, bis der Fisch einfach nicht mehr frisch ist. Also es ist eine totales Desaster.
So Fischmarkt von Peter Head in Schottland, also im großen Fischmarkt Großbritanniens. Es stand alles komplett leer. Ähm und ja, so aber.
Weil das ist frisch sein muss. Das ist warum die Fischerei Industrien so hart betroffen sind. Aber anderen Aspekten der Liefer,
von Lahm aus Whey zum Beispiel, waren waren ebenfalls betroffen und.
Es ist ja ein großes Problem,
weil die Anzahl an LKWs durch den Hafen von Dova sind heutzutage immer noch nur bei sechzig Prozent von was man normalerweise wären eine solche Periode erwarten würde.
Also das bedeutet ein großes Teil von den von den ähm Verkehr ist.
Ich finde immer noch nicht statt,
Und wir haben gesehen vor Weihnachten so eine eine gewisse Stockpink, also diversen Firmen darunter Autoindustrien zum Beispiel, die haben so viele Waren wie möglich importiert,
Die Einführung von Zollkontrollen, aber dann die Anzahl an an Verkehr ist so reduziert worden
dass jede Woche, wenn man liest die Berichte oder hört den im Radio Interviews von Leute, die in den dies diese Industrien, die Lieferketten
arbeiten, die fürchten, dass die Großbritannien kriegt einfach die Wahr nicht genug Waren in den kommenden.
Wochen, also jede Woche wird schlechter als die Woche zuvor, ja? Also.
Wir haben schon von von Produktionsstopps bei den britischen Autohersteller gehört. Engpässen in die Lieferung von ähm äh Obst und Gemüse in die Lieferketten von Supermark.
Und Großbritannien macht keine,
Einreisekontrollen, weil die die Briten haben akzeptiert, dass es geht ja nicht. Aber natürlich ein LKW ist nur rentabel, wenn es ein LKW macht, eine,
Eine Reise mit Wahr nach Großbritannien
und ist dann die gleiche LKW wird dann auch für Exporten auch dann wiederverwendet. Und wir haben schon die ersten Beispiele, dass die LKWs fahren dann leer nach die EU zurück, weil das ist einfach.
Mach wirtschaftliche mir Sinn als diese dauerhafte Papiere und und Kontrollen,
ausführen zu müssen. Ähm und dass das.
Die Kosten für Warenverkehr nach und von Großbritannien so deutlich höher geworden sind. Äh jetzt schon in den ersten Wochen ähm nach dem Brexit.
Ja insbesondere wenn sie halt leer zurückfahren, dann äh ähm kostet's ja schon mal fast das Doppelte, ne.
Ja, es gab jetzt auch diverse Berichte, man muss sich jetzt auch nochmal kurz klar machen, glaube ich, was die Situation ist. Also weil absehbar war, dass die,
Häfen
extrem überlastet sind, insbesondere durch diese spezifische geographische Lage von Dova, was ja nur so ein relativ kleiner Bereich ist, äh direkt vor den Knippen, da ist einfach kein,
so und normalerweise, wenn man da so hingefahren ist und mit der Fähre rübergefahren ist
Hat man mal gemerkt so okay, das geht dann flüssig, da fährt man irgendwie in so eine Linie rein, dann gibt's so einen Parkplatz, da wartet man irgendwie eine halbe Stunde, dann fährt man auf die Fähre drauf und dann geht's so eine halbe Stunde später auch los
Und das äh war so.
Normalerweise wie es eben lief und das geht aber jetzt nicht mehr und deswegen wurden große,
Ja, alte Flughäfen und äh neue Gelände wurden jetzt sozusagen äh aufgebaut als riesige Pufferparkplätze.
Damit auch die nicht einfach überfüllt sind, gibt es jetzt für diese Grafschaft kennt, was ja dieser Bereich ist äh äh der Dova mit einschließt, spezielle.
Einreiseerlaubnisse für Lastwagen, das heißt die dürfen nur dann mit ihren Waren überhaupt in diesen Bereich reinfahren, wenn sie vorher schon online quasi die ganzen Deklarationen abgeschlossen haben, mit einem Softwaresystem, was.
Wenn man sie um den Berichten glauben darf, im Prinzip
kaum funktioniert, vollkommen überlastet ist, schwierig ist, weil da zehn Systeme zusammengeklatscht wurden, die irgendwie alle auch erst seit Anfang Januar richtig in Betrieb sind und von all den Firmen das allererste Mal überhaupt gesehen wurden.
Da ja auch die rechtliche Grundlage dafür erst eine Woche vorher äh eigentlich klar war.
Und äh das bedeutet diese Pemitz müssen erstmal da sein, damit man überhaupt erstmal,
dieses Land fahren darf um dort dann zu warten und dort dauert's dann teilweise nochmal mehrere Tage. Ich kenn, ich hab so einen Fall mitbekommen, da wirst du wahrscheinlich auch von äh gehört haben, so 'n polnischer Lastwagenfahrer
der mit den richtigen Permids da aufgelaufen ist, aber dann hat es irgendwie mehrere Tage gedauert, wurde noch zwischen verschiedenen Parkplätzen hin und her geschickt
äh obwohl eigentlich alles richtig war, es ging sozusagen nur noch um das manuelle Finalisieren und Anerkennen dieses eigentlich richtigen Parmits und das hat dann so lange gedauert, bis dann seine Einreiseerlaubnis nach kennt, wieder expired war und dafür haben sie ihm dann noch eine Strafe äh aufgedr,
also es ist es ist wirklich aber witzig, was da gerade abgeht.
Und es gibt, es gibt auch äh Geschichten, dass das LKWs müssen irgendwo geparkt werden. Es gibt keine Parkplätze dafür und die kriegen dann Strafen, wenn die dann geparkt sind in dem falschen Ort, wo die dann,
unbedingt sein müssen, um überhaupt den Permit zu kriegen. Also es ist katastrophal, aber.
Zumindest gab's ja einen Erfolg. Dieses Permit-System ist so streng, dass die haben Schlangen von LKWs auf dem Autobahn bis jetzt vermieden.
Das bedeutet, dass die haben faktisch die Probleme so versteckt, ja? Das bedeutet
irgendwie das Journalisten so an dem M twenty, also diese diese ähm äh dieses Autobahnfotover. Da war's entsprechend hohe ich. Aber dieses System funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Also viele LKW fahren Fahrer sagen
das tun wir in der Zukunft nicht, weil weil da, weil wir wollen nicht Stunden oder tagelang irgendwo so geparkt bleiben müssen.
Der deutsche Firma DB Schenker hat einen kompletten Warnverkehr nach Großbritannien eingestellt, weil die sehen keinen Weg, um diese bürokratischen Hürden. Ähm also das ist.
Ja, das ist total schlecht geplant. Oder oder überhaupt nicht guten Dienst geplant. Aber diese Diskussion.
Irgendwie, dass es all das so schlecht ist oder oder schlecht vorbereitet ist, das kommt zur Zeit,
Beide britische Bewölkung nicht,
komplett an.
Sodass bedeutet das ja natürlich, wenn besonders, wenn man schaut oder man fordert die Experten auf Twitter, man man liest da sowas problematisch ist. Aber
Wie schwierig das ist für Britchen Unternehmen, das erkennt man nicht so wirklich in die die Berichterstattung in den britischen Medien bis jetzt.
Ja gut, das wird sich natürlich dann in den Umsätzen äh äh niederschlagen, weil das Problem ist, dass,
Also jetzt durch mehrere Faktoren, die wir schon angesprochen haben, diese Kapazität ist jetzt erstmal generell
niedriger, es dauert einfach lange, das heißt, was vorher vielleicht bei fünfzig Prozent, weil du hast gesagt, läuft jetzt bei sechzig Prozent. Dann ist es aber auch so, dass es ja sozusagen nur der, der Flo, den man beobachten kann. Insgesamt wird alles später geliefert.
Und mehrere Tage Verzögerung, das bedeutet, man kann natürlich auch an so einem Justin Time Prozess in zunehmenden Maße oder auch sofort überhaupt nicht mehr teilnehmen und für Lebensmittel ist es im Prinzip der Tod.
Dazu kommt ja noch, dass äh auch äh durch den neuen Deal, auch diese diese SPS-Checks, also diese äh Centary, Foto, Cenitary, also.
Seine Twichex. Ja, ja.
Genau, also sozusagen äh womit man verhindern will, dass es kein Spillover von Krankheiten und so weiter äh gibt, et cetera, diese ganzen Hygienevorschriften,
jetzt halt auch für Drittländer und das verzögert das Ganze halt noch weiter. Und wenn jetzt Schenker und viele andere Unternehmen werden sich das jetzt wahrscheinlich auch überlegen, überhaupt noch irgendwelche EU-Fahrer dahin zu schicken, wenn sie wissen
Auf dem Rückweg kann ich gar nichts mitnehmen, wenn ich schnell wieder da sein will und wenn ich was mitnehme, dann dauert's ewig und dann hängen wie jetzt im November, wo dann tausender Lastwagenfahrer
Im Winter Weihnachten auf der Autobahn festhängen und noch nicht mal was zu essen hatten.
Sodass dann Bürger dahin gefahren sind, um um denen noch was zu essen zu bringen zu Weihnachten. Das führt dann wiederum dazu, dass es für den Warenverkehr den Großbritannien eigentlich braucht, überhaupt nicht genug Fahrer gibt.
Ja. Genau, aber äh ihr alter stimmt, aber ich kriege den Eindruck, dass.
Dass Großbritannien als Land insgesamt hat das einfach nicht so wirklich verstanden, so wenn man.
Wenn man hört, was Dominik Rab, der Außenminister zum Beispiel gesagt hat, in einem Fernsehinterview am Wochenende. Hat all das als.
Ähm äh beschrieben oder oder Boris Jones hat so mal gesagt, ja ja es ist vorteilhaft für für britischen Unternehmer, die haben jetzt den gleichen Standard, um mit dem ganzen Welt,
zu verhandeln.
Nein, das ist nicht dem richtigen Antwort. Großbritannien, britische Firmen hatten ein Markt von achtundzwanzig EU-Länder,
ohne bürokratischen Hürden. Es war genauso einfach für eine ein Firma in Großbritannien.
Die Waren nach Frankreich zu zu schicken als von einem Staat zum einen mal anderen in England. Und das haben die Briten nicht so wirklich verstanden,
Und dann kommen dann die, die diese Argumenten von von konservativer Politik. Ja, es war nur, was ist sieben oder.
Der britischen Unternehmer haben einfach mal überhaupt was,
an anderen Ländern der EU verkauft, ja. Aber das war ein großes Teil der Britto Bruttoinlandsprodukt
Und wie doof ist das und die konservativen waren
jahrelang diese so Pro-Business Partei und die und die sagen ja okay die Lieferketten müssen sich ändern oder wir müssen einfach hören kosten oder hören bürokratischen Hürden
einfach mal akzeptieren. Ah, das ist so vollkommen eine Irre. Also alle anderen Länder der Welt wollen bürokratischen Hürden,
bauen oder die die Schwierigkeiten miteinander zu zu handeln, reduzieren. Und dann kommen die, die putsche Regierung dann hinzu und sagen, ja ja,
das ist dann eine akzeptables Preis, äh dass wir bereit sind, das zu bezahlen. Da.
Bedeutet die Schließung von britischen Unternehmen, ja? Also ITV, ja so den den Privatsender.
Hatte ein Interview gemacht vor ein paar Tagen mit dem Besitzer von einem Spielwarenfirma im Plackpool. Also eins von den ärmsten Städten Großbritannien und dieses Firma hat ein, der hatte schon eine sechshunderttausend,
Fundexporten
verloren in den ersten drei Wochen von von ähm äh des Jahres. Also es droht dann die Überlebung,
von dieser Firma und und diese Probleme.
Wenn überhaupt nicht anerkannt in der britischen politischen Debatte, nicht vom Politiker.
Als wichtiges Problem akzeptiert,
Äh und das ist auch, weil aus meiner Sicht die die Oppositionsparteien besonders laber, die haben vollkommen die falsche Strategie gehabt,
Es war für Labour wichtiger zu sagen ja wir akzeptieren das Brexit stattgefunden hat
und die kam mit dieses diese Spruch. Ja, also ein Deal ist besser als gar nichts. Aber das stimm
Zum Teil, aber das ist keine Erleichterung für für die, die Leute besonders britische Unternehmen, die sehr, sehr hart betroffen sind. Äh aber es gibt keine grundsätzlich Debatte zu dem Thema in Großbritannien gerade.
Das ist irgendwie unvorstellbar. Also das äh ich kann mir aber auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie das lange durchhalten
weil äh äh irgendwann hast du halt einfach geschlossene Firmen, hast du irgendwie einen Rückgang in der Wirtschaftsleistung, äh ist es einfach offensichtlich. Ich meine, wenn die Leute keine Jobs mehr haben und kein die Firmen keine Umsätze mehr machen und dann auch keine Steuern zahlen, dann ist das ja einfach der direkte Weg in eine in eine, in eine zusätzliche Rezession äh.
Ja, aber irgendwie aber.
Aber das da braucht man einen Halbwegs funktionsfähigen Regierung und öffentliche Debatte, um sowas.
Zu verstehen, ne? Nehmen wir hier äh ein Beispiel. Äh es ist es droht ihn aus für den einzigen internationalen
Zuglinie, Großbritannien, so zu den Eurostars, zwischen London und Paris und Bruss,
weil es gab so einen Einbruch der der Passagierezahlen.
Und was ist die Reaktion in Großbritannien? Ja.
Haben nur die Londoner Eliten verwendet bisher.
Es ist nicht so schlimm, wenn denn wenn dieses Such nicht mehr fährt.
Moment mal, das sind ja Steuerzahler, ja, wenn diese Firmen finden kein Weg, die Business-Executives von London nach Paris zu schicken, für die wir für diversen Treffen.
Das droht dann vielleicht nicht so einen wirtschaftlichen Kollaps, aber etwas, was macht dann.
Business für britischen Unternehmer deutlich schwieriger,
Es drohe dann, wenige Steuereinnahmen und Probleme für die britische Staat. Aber so eine Art, sowas zu debattieren ist zur Zeit nicht möglich in Großbritannien,
Oder wir haben auch es gab eine Reduzierung der Bevölkerung lont.
Acht Prozent während hauptsächlich wegen Korona.
Und auch zum Teil wegen Brexit. Weil die wirtschaftlichen Zukunft
Besonders in Dienstleistungsindustrien, besonders an auch ähm so Kneipenrestaurants, die sehr, sehr wichtig sind, die in Großbritannien. Diese Arten von Industrien haben jahrelang viele
Mitarbeiter aus anderen Länder der EU reingeholt. Und diese Leut,
Brexit und wegen Korone, wollen nicht mehr in Großbritannien bleiben. Also wie sehr die Zukunft der britischen,
Industrie, so so Restaurant und und Hospitality-Industrie,
überhaupt aus in den in den Jahren
nach Brexit und nach Corona. Kommen diese Leute einfach dann zurück. Ich fürchte, sie werden nicht direkt zurückkommen. Also, es wird dann eine reale Verlust in die wirtschaftliche Produktion des Landes. Aber wie.
Gravierend das ist für die britische Staat, für die überhaupt nicht in die politische öffentliche Debatte überhaupt nicht anerkannt. Und das macht mir sehr sehr großen Sorgen.
Also das finde ich jetzt auch ein bisschen bemerkenswert, dass es sozusagen ist auch immer noch nicht in die Diskussion geschafft hat, also müsste sich das nicht also müsste sich das nicht jetzt bald mal ändern. Ich meine, das ist auch einfach wir reden doch jetzt hier nicht von Peanuts.
Ja, aber jemanden muss eine Opposition aufbauen,
Ja, so für Labour, also Label will, dass diese ganze Brexit-Probleme einfach verschwinden,
Ja? Weil einige Pro-Brexit-Wahlkreisen traditionell Labour haben dann für die Konservativen in zwanzig neunzehn
gestimmt. Und dann
diese Abgeordneten, die die restlichen Abgeordneten aus nordenglischen Industriestädten der Label Partei besonders zwei betreiben diese Linie der Partei Rachel Weves und Lucy Paul, die sagen Labor muss
einfach mal beweisen, wir respektieren dieses Votum aus dieser nordenglischen ähm äh Industriestätten. Wir wollten diese Menschen zeigen, dass wir auch wie Gold Brexit dann
Aber Moment mal, das mal, wenn das,
Brexit macht, dann ist Wirtschaft in diese Orten.
Wenn nicht kaputt, zumindest schwächer also vor, das ist auch ein Problem.
Für Labor. Also das bedeutet und was wir auch wissen in diesem Brexit Deal.
Ich stehe da drin, dass nach fünf Jahren gibt es so eine Überlegung.
Brauchen wir dieses Deal, in dem jetzigen Form und in einer anderen Form. Es gibt so eine über so einer Review-Chors.
Ich finde es so unglaublich, dass Labor überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist.
Die wirtschaftlichen Folgen des Brexits. Nach einem fähigen Art und Weise zu kritisieren.
Es gibt kein Weg für Großbritannien.
Zurück in der EU. Kurz oder mittelfristig. Was man unbedingt machen muss ist den jetzigen Folgen.
Und die Lupe zu setzen, ja? Und genauso beobachten und das tut niemandem so wirklich in die britische Debatte gerade. Ähm und.
Dass dass ist ja so unglaublich schwierig zu beobachten irgendwie
Niemand bildet eine richtige Opposition gegen die Linie der Regierung zur Zeit. Und man sieht das auch in den Meinungsumfragen,
Trotz alles, trotz hunderttausend Korone Tote, trotz die Folgen des des des äh Brexit-Abkommens.
Sind die Konservativen noch in den Meinungsumfragen vorn? Äh das ist kaum zu glauben.
Ähm okay, um's vielleicht äh nochmal auch,
komplett äh zu haben, was sozusagen durch diesen Trade Deal noch alles abgedeckt ist, beziehungsweise nicht abgedeckt ist. Also es gibt ja auch noch andere,
Bereiche, die betroffen sind, was wir schon erwähnt hatten, sind ja diese Financial Services, das heißt Banken können jetzt einfach nicht ohne weiteres Produkte, Dienstleistungs,
auf dem EU-Markt anbieten, das ist auch irgendwie überhaupt nicht gecovert, das ist glaube ich steht irgendein,
möglicher äh irgendeine Greent in der Zukunft im Raum, aber derzeit ist da halt einfach nichts drin. Ich habe vorhin gerade noch gesehen, Handelsb
berichtet fünfundfünfzig Großbanken oder große Finanzdienstleister aus London sind jetzt allein in Frankfurt untergekommen. Fünfundfünfzig. Ich habe vergessen, wie viel, wie viel Trillionen Pfund äh mittlerweile schon äh den Weg in die EU gefunden haben,
Westment. Ähm das ist ja auch ein totales äh Desaster, weil da geht ja nicht nur eine Menge Geld verloren, sondern da geht ja auch eine ganze Menge. Ähm ja,
Personal dann auch mit und damit verliert London ja im Prinzip seinen Unique Setting Point einfach sozusagen die Finanzhauptstadt Europas äh zu sein.
Ja. Genau, all das stimmt. Ähm es ist ja kaum kaum zu fassen, aber all das stimmt total, ja.
Ja ähnlich sieht's im äh in der Luftfahrt aus, also auch diese Single Aviation Area äh,
jetzt nicht mehr äh teil, derzeit ist es, glaube ich, so, wenn ich's richtig sehe, Flüge in die EU und wieder zurück. Das geht.
Aber man kann halt keine Verbindungsflüge machen.
Genau, aber die die.
Sage ich so, die britischen Fluggesellschaften haben das geregelt, die haben so Tüchterfirmen in europäische Länder schon gegründet. Also da erwarte ich
keine große Schlussfolgerungen, weil die die da haben, die Firmen einfach die Kosten übernommen und und das war dann für den die Lösung.
Ja, also Easyjet hat schon seit längerem eine Niederlassung in äh Österreich, glaube ich, jetzt äh gegründet, aber das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass dann ein gewisses Steueraufkommen dann eben auch in der EU stattfindet und eben nicht mehr in UK.
Genau, das stimmt auch, ja?
Alles sehr schön, ja. Wo sie auch rausgefallen sind, ist äh der Energiemarkt. Also es gibt ja auch ein äh Single-Internal Energy Market in
äh in der EU auch daran, indem sie jetzt nicht mehr teil,
dürfte dann natürlich auch ziemlich schwierig sein, denn äh hier im Bereich Renurbils äh wo ja UK relativ gut ist, ja? Also Wind, Solar und so weiter, Kohle ist äh runter, aber man kann jetzt eben nicht mehr ohne weiteres seinen Energiebedarf
über die Leitung so ohne weiteres austauschen. Da bin ich mir noch nicht so richtig sicher, welche konkreten Konsequenzen das haben wird.
Ja also Großbritannien, obwohl Großbritannien war,
einem Energiemarkt mit der EU
es war in so die Netzbetreibung in Großbritannien war separat,
weil dem Verbindungskabel zwischen Großbritannien und Frankreich
ist die C, also nicht AC, also ich ich habe als Beamte mich mit diesen Themenfeld vor ein Jahrzehnt äh beschäftigt. Also grob die haben das.
Grob für den alltäglichen Bedarf in Großbritannien geregelt. Ähm es ist ja.
Möglicherweise problematische für Großbritannien mittelfristig, wenn britischen Firmen.
Noch noch an dem europäischen Markt teilnehmen wollen. Ähm da könnte schwierig sein, aber in die Reihe von großen Schwierigkeiten des Brexits ist dann dem Energiemarkt nicht unter den Schwierigsten.
Okay. So dann gab's ja noch den ganzen äh den ganzen Universitären Bereich, der auch vom Brexit betroffen ist.
Ja genau, also da gab's zwei,
problematischen Aspekten, also den EU Research in Development Gelder, so Harison und in Erasmus Studienaustauschsprogramm
Ähm die haben da eine Einigung gefunden, dass Großbritannien bleibt in den Horizon Programm und zahlt auch dafür.
Aber keine Einigung die Firmen für Erasmus. Also das bedeutet, dass für deutsche Studenten zum Beispiel die können dann kein Austauschjahr äh nach Großbritannien machen oder wenn ja wenn es
bilaterale Lösungen gibt mit Großbritannien, die kosten dafür werden dann
Besonders viel höher sein für Studenten, die nach Großbritannien reisen oder euch in Großbritannien studieren wollen aus.
Zum Beispiel in Frankreich oder in Italien. Ähm warum ist es so geschehen
Die EU hat so gesagt, ja so wir sind ja offen, dass Britsche Universitäten nehmen noch an Eurosmus teil, die britische Regulierung, der gesagt, nein, wir akzeptieren die finanzielle Bedingungen nicht. Wir gucken uns die Kunden unsere eigene,
Austauschsprogramm, es heißt den Turing Programm äh da und wir ermöglichen ähm es für britischen Studenten Austausche in anderen Ländern der Welt zu machen.
Problem, die Finanzen dafür sind deutlich begrenzter als mit Erasmus und für viele Studenten, es ist überhaupt nicht möglich in Neuseeland oder in Indien zu studieren, es wäre viel einfacher in die Niederlande oder in Belgien zu studieren
Also das bedeutet, Schluss für Erasmusaustausches zwischen Großbritannien,
und die EU. Aus meiner Sicht ist es eine sehr, sehr kurzfristige Entscheidung. Es ist ja für britische Universitäten,
keine keine keine gute Entscheidung,
Evasmus gilt noch in Nordirland, weil die irische Republik ist bereit, das noch zu finanzieren,
Äh und es gibt ja noch Diskussionen, ob schottische Universitäten nehmen noch teil. Also es ist,
äh es gäbe es gebe einen Vorschlag
von Nicole Stergen, das schaut sich die Universitäten dürfen auch teilnehmen. Dafür braucht sie die Zusage Londons und das hat
Boris Jumpson bis jetzt abgelehnt, obwohl die Schotten bereit sind, das zu finanzieren. Ähm äh das ist ja typisch, wie wie kurzfristig ähm und und
sie begrenzt irgendwie, das Denken denkensweise der der Londener Regierung ist.
Ja, auf Schottland, Nordirland kommen wir gleich nochmal, vielleicht um das vielleicht auch allen mal klar zu machen, die vielleicht jetzt mit diesen ganzen Programmen nicht so vertraut sind, dieses Hurison, twenty twenty oder Horizon Europ
aber es ist jetzt glaube ich äh das ist das führende äh Wissenschaftsförderungssystem der äh EU,
Spitzenforschung betreibt, dann kommt man an diesem Programm nicht drum herum. Und schon als, ich glaube, da hatten wir aber auch schon anfangs schon mal drüber gesprochen, als das Brexit Referendum war.
Also vielleicht kurz nochmal zu den Regeln, wenn jetzt ein Wissenschaftlerteam hier Forschungsgelder beantragt, dann geht man nicht einfach mit einer Gruppe dahin, sondern man muss sich europäisch vernetzen. Das heißt,
man muss mindestens glaube ich drei Länder oder so äh mit im Boot haben, die also entweder aus der EU kommen oder aus Ländern, die sich auch in dieses Forschungs äh Modell mit eingekauft haben, Israel ist
Beispiel und äh also man muss da eine gewisse Diversität äh aufweisen, um europäisch förderungswürdig
sein und kaum war das Brexit-Referendum durch zwanzig sechzehn,
sind die ganzen britischen Gruppen reihenweise schon rausgekickt worden aus diesen ganzen Anträgen, weil alle gesagt haben
ja sorry, wir haben euch lieb, aber wir müssen sehen, dass wir diese Anträge durchbekommen und wir haben jetzt einfach Angst, dass wenn wir die Briten im Boot haben, dass dann alles vorbei ist
ne, nochmal, dass es dann nochmal vier Jahre dauert, könnt ihr in dem Moment auch keiner so richtig absehen, aber das war im Prinzip eine Auswirkung, die schon da ist und die jetzt eigentlich erst durch diese Regelung in irgendeiner Form.
Sozusagen weitergelaufen.
Ist irgendwie.
Aber so, aber zumindest also wir haben dem neuen EU-Haushalt für die Periode zwanzig einundzwanzig bis zwanzig siebenundzwanzig. Ähm also da da,
die die Verhandlungen haben, was da gerettet. Wir wir wissen ja natürlich nicht, inwiefern Britschi Universitäten bleiben da vollkommen integriert, aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich besser als gar nichts.
Besser als gar nichts. Äh schlechter als äh gar nichts, weil ist nämlich gar nichts, sind auch so Beteiligungen an Programmen wie Galileo
das äh finde ich ja auch wirklich äh oberbemerkenswert, also zur Erklärung Gernileo ist dieses Satellitengestützte Navigationssystem quasi das europäische GPS,
einerseits natürlich ein Business-Teil hat, aber eben vor allem auch an militärischer Verbund ist. Und.
Aber das ist das war mal wieder ein Problem auf der britischen Seite. Also die EU hat die Briten so gesagt, okay.
In Sachen Außenpolitik, Verteidigungspolitik, Intelligence,
ist Großbritannien eins von den wichtigsten Ländern Europas
können wir irgendeine Lösung finden, damit Kooperation in diese Themenbereiche irgendwie weitergeht. Und das wollten die Briten halt nicht
Also was bedeutet es wäre möglich eine Lösung
für Großbritannien, für den Verbleib innerhalb, die den Galileo-System zu ermöglichen. Es wäre möglich, aber Großbritannien wollte das halt nicht, aus sehr ideologischen Gründen, nicht aus praktischen Gründen.
Heißt aber dann auch, dass man jetzt über äh Jahrzehnte, Milliarden an Pfund da reingesteckt hat, weil das war ja eine eine gemeinsame Entwicklung und Großbritannien war da auch nennenswert beteiligt. Es ist nicht so, dass sie da nur Geld gegeben haben, sondern es ist teilweise halt auch.
Britischen Firmen waren erdapter beteiligt.
Genau, die fliegen jetzt alle raus und nach all den Investitionen kann man noch nicht mal den Nutzen daraus ziehen, sodass Großbritannien sozusagen ohne äh zukünftiges Navigationssystem dasteht.
Ja, aber mal wieder, wie macht man so ein Argument in Großbritannien, ja? Niemanden.
Ist in der Lage genau nach dieser Art und Weise so ein so zu argumentieren. Ähm.
Es wäre eine Teilnahme, wäre sinnvoll, aber niemanden zumindest britische Politiker trauen sich so ein Argument zu machen.
Einfach alles so kaputt.
Ja genauso äh wird natürlich dann UK auch nicht teilnehmen an diesem neu aufgesetzten Kovit neunzehn Hilfsfond dieses NextGeneration EU, was zu Finanzausgleichen stattfindet. Damit war ein gewisser Hinsicht zu rechnen,
ist auf jeden Fall alles ein totales ein totales Drama, also es ist einfach, ich kann einfach die ganze Zeit nur mit dem Kopf schütteln, aber wir machen ja im Prinzip seit vier Jahren nichts anderes. Von daher ist es jetzt auch nichts Ne.
Ja ja.
Vor allem ich ich bin nicht in der Lage bei irgendeiner dieser Regelung.
Irgendwo irgendeinen Vorteil für UK zu sehen. Also egal was ich mir jetzt anschaue, was die Konsequenz von diesem Brexit ist. Es wird alles nur schwieriger.
Teurer äh unmöglich schränkt die äh Rechte der eigenen Leute mehr ein als die der EU äh bringt nix und macht nichts besser. Also.
Mir würden überhaupt gar keine Vorteile einfallen. Das nimmt irgendwie gar nichts.
Genau äh da unterstimmt, aber wir hören.
Etwas häufiger, es ist keine,
Kante Linie, aber das man sieht es in den so den Zeiten von der Daily Tellergrafs zum Beispiel. Dieses Idee,
Brexit an sich war nicht die falsche Entscheidung,
Aber die Politiker haben Brexit nicht nach dem korrekten Art und Weise ausgeführt.
Also diese diese Schwierigkeiten Brexit selbst sich nie schaut, sondern die Ausführung. Ja, also
aber das stimmt nicht. Fast alles oder fast alle Nachteile, die wir jetzt schon in der Realität sehen, haben die Brexit-Gegner schon vor zwanzig sechs in
davon gewarnt. Also was bedeutet das
Es ist nicht, dass die Regierung haben, dass nach einem falschen Art und Weise ausgeführt es wären noch großen bürokratischen Hürden, vielleicht mit einer etwas verbesserten IT-System oder so, aber negativen Auswirkungen schon,
Also irgendwie das Orgiment in Großbritannien ist Brexit muss gemacht werden, weil die Briten dafür gestimmt haben,
Aber die benannten Vorteilen des Brexits vom zwanzig sechzehn sind überhaupt nicht zu Stande gekommen.
Aber aber irgendwie so sagen, Moment mal, also diese Vorteile, die gibt's ja nicht, das bedeutet, wir brauchen eine tiefgehende Neuüberlegung, wäre das überhaupt sinnvoll? So eine Überlegung gibt es ja nicht.
Es ist irgendwie es dreht sich im Kreis, also Brexit muss ausgeführt werden, weil die Briten für Brexit gestimmt haben. Nicht weil die weil
Vorteilen von damals überhaupt noch da sind oder überhaupt möglich sind.
Oder jemals überhaupt realistisch war.
Wie es sich war.
Es ist einfach äh es ist man hat ja immer schon mit dem Kopf geschüttelt.
Aber irgendwie, es ist ja jetzt fix. Das bedeutet, dass man muss.
Irgendeine neue Zukunft für Großbritannien irgendwie.
Ausdenken. Aber Großbritannien ich.
Ich find's ja so sehr schwierig wie sieht die Zukunft von Großbritannien überhaupt jetzt aus? Weil die Stärken.
Großbritannien vorher hatten, sind deutlich schwächer geworden wegen Brexit, ja? Wir haben von den Finanzindustrien, von den kreativen Industrien gesprochen, die Pomtriben für Britischen Universitäten.
Diese Vorteile gibt's ja halbwegs noch, aber.
Sie sind ja nicht so vorteilhaft wie zuvor. Wegen die die die Brexit-Problem,
Diese Idee, dass Britschen Firmen können dann mit der Rest der Welt handeln, wenn,
Handel mit der EU schwerer geworden. Das stimmt ja für viele britische Unternehmen nicht, ja? Wenn man exportiert Spielwaren oder Bücher oder oder äh oder Lammfleisch oder Fisch oder so.
Geht halt nicht. Man kann diese verlorene Handel mit der EU einfach durch andere Handelspartner einfach nicht ersetzen. Das geht,
nicht. Und eine eine Umbau der britischen Wirtschaft, das wird ja Jahren dauern und und hat ja auch enormen Kosten. Also.
Wer hat überhaupt eine Vision von wie eine Großbritannien der Zukunft überhaupt aussieht? Es gibt ja zurzeit keine.
Ähm es gibt nur leere Sprüche.
Ich meine, wenn du sagst die Zukunft von Großbritannien muss man, glaube ich, nochmal auf ein anderes Detail äh hinweisen, was wir, glaube ich, so bisher noch gar nicht erwähnt haben.
Wir haben ja das neue Verhältnis von UK zu EU und es ist klar, dass man sich jetzt nicht mehr in dem selben Wirtschaftsraum befindet.
Aber ein anderes Versprechen der äh Brexit-Befürworter, das sich ja sozusagen an der Souveränität des eigenen Landes auch nichts ändern würde. Ganz im Gegenteil, das würde alles noch viel besser werden. Stimmt ja auch nicht.
Weil jetzt muss man mal wieder einen Unterschied machen zwischen Großbritannien und UK, weil der Teil der nicht auf der Insel Großbritannien ist, nämlich,
Nordirland nicht mehr zum Wirtschaftsraum von UK gehört. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt Waren von England nach Nordirland schicken will
dann gibt es da jetzt im Prinzip dieselbe Grenze, wie sie an Dova auch gibt mit den mit dieselben Paperwork und mit selben Verzög
und wir hatten glaube ich letzte Mal hat sie auch schon drauf hingewiesen, dass die nordirischen Politiker jetzt die Bedrohung sehen, dass die Supermärkte leer sind. Jetzt sind sie ja auch leer. Also es ist auch tatsächlich so äh.
Aber ist auch sehr interessant. Ein ein Supermarkt hat alles im Griff, in Nordirland.
Und das ist der.
Die haben so eine Riesenwerbung daraus gemacht. Alle unsere Regale sind voll, da soll die Haare ja, ja, ja, wirklich, kein Schatz.
Ja, ja, weil die haben irgendwie natürlich, die haben da eine etwas begrenztere Anzahl an Produkte, aber die die Tiharmis ja im irgendwie im Griff. Äh es es war, es war ja lustig.
Weil das quasi die einzige, die das Supermarktschäden ist in Nordirland, die eben nicht äh an der Surpline Chain von von.
Von England, der Großbritannien abhängig ist, ja gen.
Mann, ey. Ja, ja, okay. Also ich meine, es ist eh davon auszugehen, dass Nordirland sich jetzt mehr äh orientiert und das ist jetzt sozusagen auch das das nächste Ding so, was ist die Zukunft? Ich meine, als als das Brexit-Votum stattfand, ich weiß noch, dann habe ich irgendwie so ein,
kurz drüber nachgedacht, so okay, was könnte das jetzt so bedeuten? Und ich habe das, glaube ich, so ein Tweet formuliert so im Wesentlichen, mit das ist die End of The UKS Re Nold.
Jetzt nicht so so richtig konkret in in konkrete Vorhersagen gepackt, aber mir war irgendwie intuitiv klar, dass das einfach langfristig nur dazu führen kann.
Dieses doch recht volatile Konstrukt, was es schon irgendwie auch immer gewesen ist, wenn man sich so die Spannung zwischen Schottland und England und Wels und so weiter anschaut und eben auch diesen schwierigen Peace Process in in Nordirland
dass das einfach sozusagen diese magnetischen Kräfte äh äh einbüßt, die es die ganze Zeit gebraucht hat, um das irgendwie noch zusammenzuhalten.
Jetzt fliegt es auseinander.
Aber Ignorierland, wir haben in den Monaten, genau, nach dem Referendum haben wir.
Wirklich gefürchtet, was könnte das für Nordirland bedeuten? Ist Frieden in Nordirland.
Noch garantiert. Also da hatten wir unsere Fürchtung. Es es könnte schwierig gehen für Nordirland. In der Realität, was passiert, es ist.
Ist etwas anders, also es gab eine große Ernährung von Nordirland an an Irland, den irischen Republik.
Es blieb großenteils alles friedlich.
Und es sind die radikalen Parteien in Nordirland, besonders in die UP, also den den radikalsten Unionistische Partei, die dann zur Zeit Schwierigkeiten haben, also die war
für den Brexit
obwohl viele Leute gewarnt haben. Moment mal, Brexit wurde sehr, sehr bestimmt, sehr, sehr schlecht sein für Nordirland. Also es herrschen großen Spannungen innerhalb von den Junionisten im in Nordirland,
Also was nun? Also es geht es gibt ja eine sehr sehr.
Äh schnelle Ernährung an Irland und es, es gibt natürlich die offene Frage, wäre ein Verein des äh Irland mittelfristig dann möglich. Also und man muss auch sagen.
Das Vorgehen von Dublin war sehr pragmatisch sehr gut.
Ausgeführt, ja? Wir haben diese diverse faire Verbindungen zwischen Dublin und Rosslay nach Ross Coven, Shabure und Don Cark und so und so weiter. Um Großbrit.
Großbritannien einfach so umwinden. Also das grob, wenn aus der Bell fast.
Man blickt nach Doblin und man sieht zumindest ein halbwegs fielen Regierung und ein gut ordentlich regiertes Land. Wenn wir einen Blick nach London
man sieht ein Boris Johnson, der überhaupt kein Interesse an Nordirland hat und
Die pragmatische Lösung ist, wäre dann ein mittelfristig ein vereintes Irland und das ist nicht mehr.
Unerlaubt als als Frage.
Ich weiß, dass du selber noch skeptisch warst, als wir da ungefähr von Jahr drüber gesprochen hast.
Ich war ja skeptisch, aber wenn man schaut jetzt in den Meinungsumfragen ähm.
Die die Position der DOP war echt unter Druck. Ja? Es gibt.
Pragmatische Junioristen, die sehen, hey Moment mal, diesmal ging London ein Schritt zu weit. Die haben unsere.
Interessen hier überhaupt nicht respektiert. Vielleicht ist es auch nicht so schlimm.
Wenn besonders bei ihm mit irgendeinem Sonderstatus oder sowas ja ähm.
Damit wäre ja wahrscheinlich zu rechnen, ne.
Du bist besonders seit dem Aus von Theresa May. Weil weil.
Nordirland war zumindest für These May noch wichtig. Theresa May hat den härtesten möglichen Brexit.
Ausgeführt.
Ohne Nordirland in Großbritannien zu schädigen. Also das war den Kern von Theresa Mays Brexit Deal.
Boris Johnson hat all das vergessen. War für Boris Johnson vollkommen egal, weil er sah
keine schmale parteipolitischen Interessen da in Nordirland
Und ist alles die ganze Entspannung, die ganzen Probleme in Nordirland sind komplett den Show von Boris Johnson. Boris Johnsons Brexit Deal war
für den Zusammenhang des Vereinigten Königreichs ein sehr schlechtes Deal.
Ja, weil jetzt ist de facto Nordirland eigentlich schon Teil der Republik Irland, also sie befinden sich jetzt im selben Wirtschaftsraum, haben offene Grenzen, die haben sie nicht zu UK, also im Prinzip ist es schon abspalten. So, de facto ist es sozusagen.
Ja, aber die haben.
Es hat diese so sehr waage Status ja? Ähm aber ja wirtschaftlich die Lieferketten für Nordirland werden in der Zukunft mehr durch Stoplin laufen als durch London.
Genau und so wird es halt in zunehmendem Maße abhängig äh äh abgehängt und äh ich meine, das ist ja absehbar, dass das dann einfach darauf hinausläuft, dass die Nordiren halt sagen, okay,
de facto sind wir eh schon Teil Irlands was haben wir irgendwie von England zu erwarten
wenn dann und das hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal thematisiert, dass Karfreitagsabkommen sieht ja auch explizit vor, dass wenn festgestellt wird, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer das feststellen muss, aber wenn sozusagen sich
zeichnet, dass es ein Umschwung in der öffentlichen Meinung gibt und danach sieht's ja ansatzweise schon aus.
Könnte sich auch noch weiter verstärken, denke ich. Wenn's vor allem mit England noch weiter
Runde geht, ne? Dann dann könnte man eben ein neues Referendum beantragen, dann müsste man sich natürlich mit der Republik Irland abstimmen und ich würde mal vermuten, das läuft dann auf so was hinaus wie okay, das ist dann so quasi nicht.
Nicht eine Provinz wie alle anderen, sondern die hat irgendeinen Sonderstat
und die die schützt die Rechte dieser Unionisten und Problematik und so weiter und ist irgendwie autonom regiert, aber ist halt Teil des irischen Staates.
Glaube es haben auch schon es dürfen ja alle in Nordirland die irische Nationalität annehmen und ich glaube hast du die Zahl der die Quote im Kopf, es war.
Extrem viel.
Hoch, ja, ja, ja.
Also es ist mehr als die Hälfte der Leute, die in Nordirland sind, haben bereits einen irischen Pass und ich glaube, der Rest wird sich auch noch einen holen, weil dadurch
nimmt man natürlich wiederum an der EU teil und hat irgendwie all diese ganzen Einschränkungen, die wir vorhin diskutiert haben halt nicht. So und damit ist es ist irgendwie absurd, dass ein Teil,
Vereinigten Königreichs quasi alle Leute, die da wohnen, sind Bürger eines anderen Staates. Also das ist einfach durch das Thema. Als.
Genau, er ist verrückt.
Aber auch die Diskussion, ja der der Minister im
Investments, dafür Nordirland zuständig ist, Brand and Learis. Dankeschön, aber es ist ja so vorteilhaft für Nordirland, die bleiben Teil von Großbritannien, die haben alle Vorteile des EU-Binnenmarktes
Moment mal so, warum hat Großbritannien dann keine Vorteile diese EU-Binnenmarktes? Das ist so eine Ehre, ja? Und dann haben die Chancen so gesagt, hey Moment mal, also die Vorteile wollen wir auch
Äh also es ist irgendwie dass die konservativen Sehen, die Situation in Nordirland für die Not ihren Vorteilhaft.
Aber Lehmen das für den Rest von Großbritannien ab. Es ist verrückt.
Ideologie. Ein äh weiterer Bereich der.
Und auf eine interessante Art und Weise abgespalten ist es gibt. Für Gibraltar gab's ja überhaupt gar keine Einigung innerhalb dieses Stils, also hat Gibralt ja jetzt auf eigene äh.
Kraft hin mit Spanien eine Einigung erzielt und die sieht jetzt so aus, dass äh geprallter dem Schengenraum beitritt.
Ja, das ist ja lustig, das ist ein großes Erfolg für meinen Blog. Weil das habe ich äh äh zum ersten Mal in zwanzig dreizehn vorgeschlagen als Lösung für gebrach.
Aha.
Also wenn es Probleme an der Grenze einfach den Schengeneraum beitreten und dann so ist es der ja gelungen, ne? Äh ganz ehrlich, also Gebrater hat sechsundneunzig Prozent für den Verbleib.
Gestimmt die bei bei dem Referendum zwanzig sechs sehen, die sehen dass es läuft ja da gar nichts ohne einen halbwegs.
Guten Verbindung mit Spanien. Es ist jetzt einfacher für Spanier in Gebraten einzureisen als für Briten. Das ist ja ein bisschen verrückt,
Aber mal wieder okay, Nordirland spielt schon eine nur eine sehr kleine Rolle in die politische öffentliche Debatte,
überhaupt keine Rolle in die britische politische Debatte die Falklandinseln sogar noch weniger. Ähm.
Also ja, also das ist Völki Bralzer eine etwas ungewöhnliche, aber eine sehr gute prägnatische Lösung. Also eine Art von eine pragmatische Lösung, was
den die britische Region komplett ausschließt ähm ja ähm,
Sie haben was gelernt und die die haben dann eine äh etwas Gutes für die, für die Menschen, die da leben. Ähm mit Spanien verhandelt aus meiner Sicht.
Ja, aber das bedeutet, dass es jetzt ein Teil des britischen Territoriums gibt, nämlich Gibraltar, wo die Grenzen von der EU kontrolliert werden.
Ja das ist ja.
Ist völlig absurd. Take control of our borders, ja.
Aber da nicht. Es ist aber mal wieder.
Was sind die Kerninteressen der Regierung von Boris Johnson? Die eigene Parteiinteressen.
In dem weitesten Sinn so zu verteidigen. Für die Konservativen, so baut nur die Irland gebrauchter Vokland Inseln.
Offiziell auf Papierteil von Großbritannien bleiben, ja oder oder gehören Großbritannien noch. Es ist ja diese Menschen vollkommen egal, was praktisch.
Stattfindet. Komplett egal.
Ja? Äh irgendwie das betrifft die britische Debatte überhaupt nicht. Ja, obwohl ich komplett absurd ist.
Ja und vor allem, ich meine, das ist natürlich auch äh ähm in irgendeiner Form. Es gibt ja da verschiedenste äh Abstufungen. Ich will K
die unter es gibt so UK äh also es gibt ja Sittisons und es gibt äh Subritis, alles gibt British Sittistens und es gibt Subjects. Ich glaube die Britta und so weiter, das ist British Sumjek, ne? Ähm.
Forclidinseln, weil du das jetzt gerade angesprochen hast.
Die sind ja jetzt nochmal in einer besonders äh schwierigen Situation. Ich habe jetzt darüber keine Berichte gelesen, aber was ich noch weiß, ist wovon leben die Folklandinsel? Ich meine, da leben nicht viele Leute.
Fischereipolitik.
Verkaufen, die ihre Fische in Argentinien.
Ja und in die EU, ja? Und es gibt ja dann genau die gleichen Probleme für die Fischereiexporte aus.
Inseln nach die EU, es ist für schottischen Fisch äh Fischereiexporten gibt.
Wovon sollen die noch leben da.
Die haben ja enormen Schwierigkeiten. Wir, wie die Fürchten, das ist für einen großen Auswanderung geben von den Menschen auf den Vocklenseln, die dann in Großbritannien in der Zufuhr leben mussten, genau deswegen.
Von denen lebt und dann holt sich das Argentinien wieder zurück.
Ja, dann sehen wir mal, ob ob ob Boris Johnson dann dann mal wieder ähm ein, ein kleines Krieg da startet, äh wie sein Vorgänge Margret Fatja. Ähm.
Also es gibt ja, es gibt ja so einige Übersehgebiete, das haben ja irgendwie auch nicht alle äh so drauf, also es gibt ja überall so komische Inseln, die äh von ja offiziell zu zu UK gehören.
Aber dir keiner so auf dem auf dem Zettel hat und dir jetzt alle das selbe Problem haben in der Karibik, diverse Länder, äh Pazifik.
Im Südatlantik, ja, ja.
Genau. Gut.
Kommen wir nochmal zu Schottland. Weil Schottland finde ich immer insofern äh noch das spannendste Thema, als dass die sich ja nun wirklich mit den Engländern dann auch dieselbe Insel teilen.
Von Wales reden wir auch gleich noch, aber äh Schottland ist natürlich auf jeden Fall der bistigere äh Partner.
Weil die halt mit Nikolas Störch und wirklich auch eine eine politische Figur am Start haben, für die man sich nicht unbedingt schämen muss.
Und ähm hat mir ja nun auch schon ein paar Mal äh diskutiert, jetzt geht's ja wieder einen Schritt weiter. Im Mai sind dort die schottischen Parlamentswahlen, alle gehen, glaube ich, davon aus, dass die SMP dann die äh absolute Mehrheit zurückerobern
wird und die Umfragen für ein mögliches Referendum über die Unabhängigkeit Schottlands von von UK.
Gehen glaube ich so ein bisschen durch die Decke, liegen jetzt irgendwo bei fünfundfünfzig Prozent oder war es sogar noch mehr, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau.
Ja, also es war in den letzten Umfragen zwischen dreiundfünfzig und ich denke, die höchste war achtundfünfzig Prozent. Ja, ähm.
Sieht nicht gut aus.
Ja, aber die Situation ist echt problematisch, weil nach.
Britischen Recht braucht man die Zusage Lombens um.
Ein Referendum, ein falsches Referendum zu den Unabhängigkeit Schottlands überhaupt auszuführen.
Und die Linie in London,
bleibt hart. Also Boris Johnson und Michael Gove, der der faktisch der Brexit-Minister, der der auch ursprünglich aus Schottland ist, sagt
Ja die
die Schotten hat mir eine einmalige Chance äh sich über den Unabhängigkeit zu entscheiden
wir wir lassen kein keinen zweiten Referendum zu.
Und ohne die Zusage Londons ist es dann für die Schotten sehr schwierig. Es war ein Referendum dann zu organisieren. Also es droht dann eine Art
Situation wie in in Katalonien, dass die Katalanen wollten vor ein paar Jahren ein Referendum machen ohne die Zusage von,
Madrid. Und ich habe ja Angst, dass es könnte zu den gleichen Situationen dann kommen in in.
In in Großbritannien. Da gibt's auch ja ein Problem, dass die die.
Alle Parteien, die in dem Longer Parlament vertreten sind, außer die schottischen Nationisten.
Wollen kein zweites Referendum in Schortland, das soll auch die Labo-Partei die Labour Partei von von äh von Kia Starmer, die haben so eine Überlegungskomitee so ins ins Leben gerufen.
Um so eine neue Position für Schottland innerhalb des freien Königreichs auszudenken, aber die lehnen ja auch ein zweites Referendum ab. Also was bedeutet das, es könnte,
sehr, sehr strichig werden im Mai, Juni.
Wenn dann London sagt, hey sorry Schotten, ihr habt für Mehrheit nicht für den so für Pro-Austrittsparteien gestimmt, aber ein zweites Referendum lehnen wir ab.
Weil.
Gibt ja natürlich Angst in London, dass wenn so eine zweites Referendum stattfindet, dass diesmal die Schotten werden für den Unabhängigkeit dann dann abstimmen. Und die Schotten schauen nach.
Nordirland, die schauen auch nach Irland, ja
Ich hatte selbst ernsthafte Diskussionen mit mit schottischen äh Nationalisten. Wie könnte man den den irischen Beispiel nehmen, neue, faire Verbindungen zwischen Rosive in der Nähe von Adam Bra,
nach anderen europäischen Ländern anbieten, um als Weg England ähm um um zu fahren zum Beispiel.
Aber was ist die Lösung? Wenn London lässt, einen Unabhängigkeitsreferendum zu.
Chancen sind hoch, dass die Schotten dann gehen und dann Great Britton ist dann nur England plus Wales, faktisch.
Und wenn sie das nicht zulassen, dann herrscht eine immer stärkere Opposition in in Adamra, also es gi
da keine gute Lösungen. Wir hören von Boris Johnson und Kiest Dame nur einfach leere Sprüche. The Union is bet it together, blaw, ja, aber ohne konkreten Vorschläge.
Und wenn man sieht was Westminste getan hat in Sachen Brexit.
Auch macht, was Schortland hat, also zum Beispiel in Sachen Fischereipolitik oder Regionalpolitik. Namen London dieses Macht von,
also es kann einfach so nicht weitergehen.
Arbeit zurzeit, ich bin so verdammt pessimistisch, ich sehe keine gute Lösungen, weil ich sehe, dass dass Boris Johnson.
Überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist, entweder Schottland ein ernsthaftes Angebot zu machen, okay? Wenn wir zusammenbleiben,
Das sind die gute Gründe zusammenzubleiben oder ein Angebot, ein zweites Referendum zu machen. Also die sind die zwei, die zwei Optionen und die lehnen
lehnen die die Westminstalits Gebäude ab.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, der Druck würde sich ja doch weiter erhöhen. Ich meine, das kann man ja nicht komplett ignorieren, wenn dann äh die äh Umfragen vielleicht noch weiter steigen auf was weiß ich, sechzig, siebzig Prozent, das äh.
Ist das ist das wichtig für? Ja, ist das wichtig für Boris Johnsons? Äh ähm Chancen wiedergewählt zu werden in zwanzigvierundzwanzig. Nein. Genau, im Gegenteil.
Bei seinem Wähler im England kommt das gut an.
Diese nervigen Leute in den Provinzen, ja die müssen ja akzeptieren, wer der Chef hier ist. Na, ich habe das ein bisschen übertrieben, aber nicht so ganz.
Ja gut, aber wenn es dann wirklich zu so katalonischen äh Verhältnissen kommt und sich da äh äh wirklich dann auch den Widerstand äh äh regt, dann kommt ja der Staat überhaupt nicht mehr zur Ruhe.
Ja, aber man muss nicht vergessen, dass Boris Johnson denkt, dass er kann.
Alles so schön reden irgendwie. Wer das er kann, einfach die Menschen, wenn er eine eine gute Rede hält, kann er alle überzeugen.
Ja, also nehmen wir den Beispiel von Erasmus, ja?
Also alle haben so gesagt, hey, Großbritannien muss in Erasmus bleiben, ja? Ich habe auch vor Monaten debattiert mit Schotten, ja, könnte Schottland noch in der in dem Erasmus-Programm bleiben. Es war so klar,
Das Nikolas Sterging wäre bereit, etwas Politisches daraus zu machen und dann.
Boris Johnson reagierte, schocktiert. Ja, wieso kann es sein? Show, man kann da auf keinen Fall in den Erasmus bleiben. Aber weil er denkt, keine zwei Schritte im Voraus.
Das können wir jetzt machen in diesem Podcast. Wir können ernsthaft die die Schwierigkeiten und die Probleme für Schottland ernsthaft debattieren.
Aber in Großbritannien zurzeit das ist nicht wie Boris Johnson denkt. Er denkt, es ist ausreichend ist, einfach mal zu sagen, ja wir sind alle besser, wenn wir zusammen bleiben.
Ey, lacht jedes Mal, wenn wenn
schottischen Nationalisten im im englischen Unterhachs irgendeine Frage stellen, die nehmen diese Fragen überhaupt nicht ernst, die nehmen die Brexit-Auswirkungen äh auf dem schottischen Wirtschaft ähm überhaupt nicht ernst
die denken Boris Johnson denkt, dass Nicole Sterge in irgendeine blöde Regionalpolitikerin ist, obwohl sie eigentlich die fähigsten fähigsten,
Politikerin Großbritanniens ist. Also er nimmt die Probleme einfach nicht ernst. Er hat keine Strategie.
Ich stimme dir vorkommen zu, es könnte sehr gefährlich sein, aber das sieht er nicht und versteht er nicht. Weil ich denke, kein, kein zwei oder drei Schritten im Voraus.
Das einzige, ich finde sie wirklich schade, weil ich ich wäre wegen Kovit. Ich wäre so gerne äh nach ähm
nach Schottland fahren, um ein bisschen Wahlkampf da zu machen vor dem schossischen Parlamentswahl. Aber wegen die Situation mit mit Korone. Ich denke, das ist leider nicht möglich wird ähm aber.
Es wird bestimmt einen sehr spannenden Wahlkampf sein in Schottland im im April Mai, wenn man überhaupt so, wo kriegst du mal einen Wahlkampf überhaupt durchführen kann.
Ja, aber denken sie, denkst du, dass da irgendetwas anderes als eine breite Zustimmung für die SNP denkbar ist?
Nee, nee, es wird eine auf jeden Fall eine sehr breite Zustimmung für die äh SMP, auch für die Grünen sind für einen unabhängigen Schottland. Es war, es wird katastrophal sein, für Labour und schlecht für die Konservativen.
Die ohnehin jetzt nicht besonders gut dastehen in Schottland, von daher da auch nicht mehr sehr viel zu verlieren haben, aber äh Leber ja durchaus, ne.
Also nicht mal zusammenfassen darf äh.
Es ist, es ist es ist wirklich alles schlimm und es äh macht irgendwie nicht so richtig den,
Eindruck so. Was ich nicht so richtig verstehen kann, ehrlich gesagt oder was wo ich mal so stellvertretend jetzt vielleicht auch für alle in Deutschland so ein bisschen spreche.
Überhaupt für die EU. Man kann sich das nicht vorstellen, dass man,
solange so nach fortgesetzten Delusion äh unterliegt und unterzogen wird und und es keinen Moment der Befreiung gibt. Ich meine, wir sehen jetzt gerade, also SW Speak, ich glaube in diesem Moment beginnt gerade die Vereidigung von Joe Biden in den USA
Trump ist jetzt irgendwie äh raus und äh auch wenn dort noch nicht alles in Ordnung ist, haben sich dann doch zumindest in gewisser Hinsicht ordnende Kräfte durchgesetzt, so. Ich meine, es gab schon immer eine zählerische Mehrheit für die Demokraten, aber.
Sie haben's dann halt auch geschafft, sich gesellschaftlich
so weit aufzurütteln, um einfach gegen diesen Mob und den kann man jetzt glaube ich nach den Ereignissen der letzten Wochen auch so wirklich nennen, äh sich gegen den durchzusetzen, auch wenn es zahlenmäßig immer noch alles,
irgendwo unvorstellbar ist so, aber die gesellschaftliche Stimmung zumindest in einem intellektuellen oder sagen wir mal in einem aufgeklärten Teil der der Gesellschaft ähm,
die ist dann halt einfach ausreichend gekippt und man hatte einfach verstanden, dass man sich um dieses Problem kümmern muss.
Ist es ja nicht so, dass in Großbritannien nur stumpfsinnige Nationalisten leben würden, sondern es ist ja auch ein Land voll äh reich mit äh klugen Menschen und und wie einer demokratischen Kultur. Was ist denn mit diesem Bevölkerungsteil,
ist der nicht in der Lage sich zu organisieren, äh ist man da noch nicht aufgewacht? Ist das irgendwie man sieht doch die Probleme.
Viele Leute haben sich von dem alltäglichen Politik Großbritannien so einfach abgeschaltet.
Können die Diskussionsprogramme BBC oder die Zeitungen einfach nicht mehr hören oder lesen. Die haben den Eindruck, dass.
Alles ist nur schlimm.
Und ich wird nicht besser, also niemanden verkörpert irgendeine Hoffnung in Großbritannien, außer Stargin. In,
in Schottland. Auch Labor als Oppositionspartei und Kia Starma, als Parteichef, die sind so risikoervers.
Wenn man fragt, den britischen die britische Bewölkerung.
War Brexit eine gute Idee oder eine schlechte Idee, es gibt guten Mehrheiten jetzt der Menschen, die sagen es war eine schlechte Idee.
Wie gut war die Ausführung von Brexit? Da gibt's ja auch eine Mehrheit der Menschen, die sagen, ja die die Regierung haben das schlecht ausgeführt.
Aber das spürt man in den Meinungsumfragen nicht. Also Labor ist so es geht mehr oder weniger auf dem gleichen Prozentzahl.
Als die Konservativen die liberalen sind noch sehr schwach, ja? In Wales kommen dann die valisischen Nationisten etwas voran, aber irgendwie.
Wie macht man überhaupt eine Protestbewegung in Großbritannien? Man brauche dafür Finanzen, man braucht.
Überzeugende Persönlichkeiten.
Und irgendwie alles ist so sehr stumpf irgendwie die Debatte, also das das Leute, die guten Ideen haben oder eine gewisse Optimismus,
irgendwie strahlen, die kommen ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht irgendwie voran. Das.
Mann, es gibt keine Visionen, es gibt keine keine Zukunftsidee für Großbritannien, also ah das ist so sehr negativ, alles ist so es gibt.
Keine kein Weg nach vorn irgendwie auch von Labour äh und und das ist fast alles dieses sozusagen so so verdammte prämierend macht, ja? Ein.
Auf eine Seite, wenn man schaut in den Meinungsumfragen. Optimismus wäre möglich, ja? Die.
Die Wiele wollen etwas besseres, aber niemand bietet das zurzeit an, außer in Schottland und zum Timing Wales. Aber im im England ist sozusagen so irgendein so eine politische Wüste. Es gibt nichts Gutes.
Und und die öffentliche Debatte ist so.
So irgendwie so schlecht, also äh die die es ist wie das besonders die Engländer verstehen sich nicht mehr.
Ähm vielleicht verwende ich nicht die richtigen Wörter, um das zu beschreiben, aber.
Irgendwie die demokratischen Systemen funktionieren nicht mehr. Ja, es braucht so eine sehr tiefgehende Überlegung über die Zukunft des Landes und das findet zur Zeit nicht statt.
Also muss das alles erstmal wieder noch ein bisschen schlechter werden, bevor es bess.
Es muss, es muss sowas schlechter werden, ja? Ähm schau mal auf, wir waren es nicht so wirklich debattiert, ja, aber.
Es gibt ein Parlamentswahling Wayous, ja, in im äh auch Anfang Mai.
Jetzt die valisischen Nationalisten in diesem Jahr auf zweiundzwanzig Prozent.
Und da habe ich selbst meine eigene Familie, das war meine Eltern wohnen in in New Pott in Südwedes. Ja, obwohl mein mein Vater es ist in lestisch hier in England geboren.
Mich gefragt, zwanzig zwanzig neunzehn als als Großbritannien auch an einem Europawahl teilgenommen hatte.
Wäre es für mich besser für Play Combi zu wählen? Moment mal da, What the helle you doing? Also du wählst für Plate Kombi wählen, ja? Du bist in England geboren. Ja, aber ich denke, ja so die sind pro-europäisch, könnte es doch noch Sinn machen.
Moment mal, so wenn meine eigene Fahrt überlegt für Pride Comiz zu stemmen.
Das ist ja eine krasse Änderung. Ich weiß nicht, ob Apfel für wen er dann diesmal.
Bei den Parlamentsfallen wählt. Aber wenn Playkomi,
bietet an den proeuropäischsten Positionen, ja? Die können ja wirklich an an Ex-Labor und Ex-Liberale Wähler wirklich,
wirklich viele Stimmen ja gewinnen. Also da da ändert sich ja auch etwas in ein bisschen in Wales. Es ist ja interessant, aber Englisch, also Brexit, all das zusammenzufassen.
Brexit war kein kein Problem.
Ganz Großbritannien. Brexit war etwas sehr Englisches. Das war irgendwie englisches Nationalismus. Und das ist, was wir jetzt mal wieder sehen.
Not, Irland geht seinen eigenen Weg. Schottland will ein zweites Referendum. Es herrscht jetzt etwas ganz anderes jetzt in Wales.
Aber die Probleme bleiben ja noch in England. Also kann es sein, dass sie in ein Jahrzehnt.
England bleibt, bleibt alleine außerhalb der EU und wir reviert debattieren dann ein Wiedereintritt, schaut an, sondern wieder Eintritt von Wheys und und Nordirland hat ein
Sonderstatus. Also wenn kein Politiker kommt an der Macht
in England mit eine gute moderne Vision für die wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen Zukunft von Großbritannien insgesamt. Dann reißt alles auseinander innerhalb von einem Jahrzehnt.
Ja, das ist so der Ausblick, den man jetzt geben kann. Sieht nicht so, sieht nicht so toll aus. Also ich.
Manchmal manchmal kommt ja der Wandel dann doch schneller als man äh denkt. Ich meine es gibt hier einfach so viele Faktoren, die.
So ein Axelerationspotential haben
also sowohl diese Nordirlandsituation, wenn die dann erstmal plastisch sich entwickelt. Die wirtschaftliche Situation, wenn die sich jetzt noch weiter verschlechtert, die politische Debatte mit Schottland,
dann wohl sogar Wales, was ja sozusagen und ich glaube
ganz am Anfang, als wir darüber gesprochen haben über die Rolle von Walzer hast du gesagt, na ja Wales, das das hängt so fest mit England zusammen, da dingt keiner im Traum daran, dass man irgendwie getrennte Wege gehen könnte. Wenn sogar sowas jetzt auf einmal denkbar ist
dann wird natürlich auch irgendwann so eine junge Generation kommen und sagen hör mal irgendwie wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie alle unsere Rechte abgegeben für das
So, dass es das ist alles, was wir jetzt irgendwie kriegen auf unserem Kuchen, ihr habt sie doch nicht mal alle geht bitte.
Dann äh ja, dann ist es eine Frage, wie die Beschleunigung ist.
Corona hatte auch da in Wales, so wie auch in Schottland, also wenn man schaut in den Zahlen, ja? Also
es gab fast genauso viele Tote in Nord in Schottland und in Wales, als es in England gab, also es gibt die gleichen Schwierigkeiten
aber der der valisische Gesundheitsminister,
kommt einfach besser rüber. Der ist ein normaler Mensch. Ja, der, der, der lügt ja nicht wie die in in
im äh Westminster. Also auch in Wales hat man verstanden durch Corona. Es gibt einen anderen Weg, ja. Vielleicht eine schwierigere manchmal. Aber zumindest, dass man kann Politik einfach mal
anders als in Westminster ausführen. Das haben auch die Valise kapiert.
Na ja, vielleicht versteht's dann der Rest ja auch irgendwann. Gut John. Ich denke an der Stelle können wir äh hier mal wieder einen Punkt machen. Jetzt ist ähm.
Was ich so gefühlt so ein bisschen in so einer Zäsur angekommen hier mit unserer äh Serie, so. Brexit ist jetzt irgendwie äh delivert. Jetzt wird es sich erstmal so ein bisschen auskäsen. Ich habe nur so den Eindruck.
Ding ist noch nicht durch, also es wird interessant bleiben, dass äh auf jeden Fall noch zu äh verfolgen. Wir warten jetzt erstmal ab, wie sich das alles so,
äh entwickelt und dann schauen wir nochmal, ob wir da nochmal was zusammengefakt bekommen.
Lass uns mal vielleicht diese Themenfälle mal wieder debattieren,
kurz vor dem schottischen Parlamentswahl, weil dann werden wir bestimmt wissen, wie sieht's aus, wirtschaftlich in Großbritannien,
Wie sind die praktischen Auswirkungen und bleiben so die Schotten auf Kurs? Ähm also das wäre dann sehr interessant zu der.
Das stimmt, das ist ein guter Zeitpunkt. Na gut, dann machen wir für heute erstmal Schluss. Ich sage tschüss, vielen Dank schon. Und äh ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei äh UKW. Ich sage äh tschüss und bis bal.